[Music]
hello, how are you, greetings, andrés gonzález,
and this is a brave news report for today,
thursday, september 23, today will be the
funeral of one of the
commercial officers who died after a
road accident in spring valley a week ago,
joshua castellano died in a
road accident that involved several police officers from
that city while they were visiting ours,
the one driving was identified as
robert ferrán, he is facing charges of
driving under the influence of
toxic substances and severely before a judge this
morning
, teachers are being denied medical coverage
or your bills are being
referred to collections because your
insurance doesn't pay what is required the
problem here is that the bills
related to health are much
higher than the amount the
insurance receives the school district board will meet today
to discuss  the
issue
passengers of the artist buses and they
say they have to wait longer
than normal the company indicated that there is
a shortage of drivers some of
them returned after several months of not
working or never returned after the
closure due to the pandemic another
reason is the
construction projects around the city
which cause traffic delays
the transport system is
working  with contractors to
fix the problem and be able to have more
staff in the meantime passengers are asked
to be a little more
patient and now we turn to see
the weather forecast we will have a
hot sunny sky with temperatures
reaching 90 degrees we
will keep up with this weather  For the rest
of the week, however, on Monday
the winds will return and slightly cooler temperatures are expected. There
will be a slight possibility of rain in
the mountains.